[Música]
aumento de hablar de economía aquí en
directo américa edición nocturna hasta
con nosotros en el estudio jorge hurtado
jorge muy buenas noches comenzamos
hablando de esa controvertida decisión
de ucrania de detener el tránsito de un
tercio del gas que transporta hacia
europa procedente de rusia claro
santiago la operadora de la red de
transmisión de gas es grande anunció que
desde este miércoles se verá obligada a
interrumpir de forma temporal el
tránsito del gas hacia europa según la
empresa porque las fuerzas de ocupación
interrumpen las operaciones y no podrán
transportar gas a través del punto de
conexión de zouhier annika en la
frontera con rusia por esa estación está
pasado hasta ahora
32,6 millones de metros cúbicos de gas
al día esto es un tercio del total que
ucrania transportaba hasta europa rusia
ha estado enviando gas a través de
ucrania con normalidad pese a la guerra
pero quien había advertido de que el
flujo podría interrumpirse un portavoz
de gazprom la semiestatal rusa confirmó
que fueron notificados por ucrania de la
interrupción pendiente rusia suministra
alrededor del 40 por ciento de la
demanda de gas europea y aproximadamente
un tercio de ellas se envía a través de
ucrania lo que la convierte en una pieza
clave de presupuesto para la seguridad
energética de todo el continente y si
hay un país que depende de ese gas y ese
petróleo ruso es alemania y precisamente
hay un estudio que revela el impacto que
tendría la economía alemana en caso de
un posible embargo de hidrocarburos
procedentes de rusia en ese país la
economía más grande de europa siempre
estas proyecciones económicas hablan de
el mejor el moderado y el peor escenario
bueno en el caso del peor escenario las
estimaciones es que alemania perdería
hasta el 12 por ciento de su producto
interno bruto como consecuencia de una
interrupción inmediata del suministro de
gas ruso según un estudio del instituto
de estudios macroeconómicos en caso de
que los efectos sean menos contundentes
el efecto sobre el pib podría estar en
una caída del 3,2 por ciento el estudio
también advierte que podría haber
fuertes repercusiones sobre el mercado
laboral y un aumento del desempleo y se
reduciría también el potencial
productivo de ese país cerca de la mitad
del gas que se consume en alemania como
fuente de energía como materia prima
proviene de rusia dependencia que hace
que alemán se abstenga de imponer
sanciones o embargos al gas ruso
hablemos ahora de otras previsiones
económicas que deja la guerra en ucrania
bueno según el banco europeo de
reconstrucción y desarrollo como
consecuencia de la guerra la economía
ucraniana caerá un 30 por ciento en 2022
y la rusa un 10 por ciento este banco
proyecto en marzo pasado una caída para
ucrania del 20 por ciento de su economía
pero ahora sube el estimado de
contracción a 30% la institución insiste
en que sus pronósticos para este y el
próximo año pueden variar en la senda
del decrecimiento dependiendo de la
duración de la guerra y las posibles
restricciones a los flujos de
exportaciones de gas y otras materias
primas rusas importante dar a conocer
esa acta de la última reunión del comité
de política monetaria del banco central
brasileño la potencia suramericana que
opinan sobre este contexto global el
emisor brasileño asegura que la
inflación generalizada que se vive en el
mundo y una posible desaceleración
global tendrá efectos en el crecimiento
económico de ese país el organismo
admitió que decidió elevar la tasa
básica de interés de brasil hasta el 12
75 por ciento su mayor nivel desde 2017
es un intento para frenar la inflación
el documento del banco central asegura
que las presiones inflacionarias y la
paralización de actividades en varias
regiones de china atrás harán aún más el
proceso de normalización del
abastecimiento de insumos industriales
los analistas dan cuenta de que la
economía brasileña sufrirá una
desaceleración tras haber crecido un 46
por ciento en 2021 indicadores como las
faldas principales bolsas wall street
cerró mixto tras tres días de pérdidas
en los principales índices sobre todo en
el tecnológico nasdaq en europa el
selectivo frankfurt cerró con un aumento
del 1,15 por ciento en américa la bolsa
mexicana de valores avanzó un 0,12 por
ciento en su principal indicador así
como eliminó una racha de tres sesiones
a la baja y la cifra del día para el
cierre
62 mil 400 millones de pesos mexicanos
esa es la derrama económica que se
espera por el día de las madres en ese
país se estima que hay
35,2 millones de madres en mexico que
hoy celebran su día y quienes
felicitamos por supuesto felicitaciones
para todas ellas muchas por este reporte
de ustedes sigan con nosotros que ya
viene el debate
[Música]